hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey and I'm Andrew Andrew
Terpening he's visiting from Texas he's
a fellow patron member and I said sure
come on the channel because you're
visiting look how good of guys we are
we're not increases are in but not
opportunists at all they're encouraged
is feeling my good-looking value guys
will send me more views now all you
gotta do is like something up the theme
song and then we'll be that's the next
step you know we had a lot of hot girls
now we gotta bring on hot guys here the
next level Linda then we'll get a bigger
female Debbie favored yeah yeah a lot of
people are talking about this on
Instagram and Twitter people are like
really flipping out about the first
photos that have been released of Josh
Brolin as cable and Deadpool - have you
guys seen photos yet no I'm one photo
I've ever seen none photos I know you
have a teddy bear on his belt well
here's the variety photos right here oh
look I got one full foot everything
that's actually looks pretty good looks
really accurate dad cable looks but I
would take it in - Wow oh yeah the giant
God - teddy bear area damn that looks
straight out of the Aaronic for you
legit dude to a premium cable
thanks Ryan Reynolds I'm not really here
to do like a lot of commentary on
specifically the photos but after seeing
Josh Brolin in this and knowing who Josh
Brolin is as such a serious actor yeah
than some comedies and he was Tommy Lee
Jones and then black 3 and we watched
the video so they could have more
information and backstory on who cable
actually is and it got me thinking is
this Deadpool movie going to actually
try to link to the x-men universe a
little more specifically this time
around in the Deadpool
post-credit scene he did tease that like
cable will probably be the villain in
the next one I was watching the screen
junkies video where they had Tim Miller
to come on for to do the Deadpool on his
trailer commentary and even Tim Miller
was admitting like that a villain was
weak in
Deadpool movie so I'm like yeah they
want to give a better villain for
Deadpool to the cable is such an
essential part of the x-men universe oh
yeah from the information we gather he
is the son of Scott Summers hence his
name Nathan Summers is a time traveler
and he had like telekinetic powers it
has specific vendetta's with like
apocalypse I know they have like
connection to the x-men universe
Deadpool comes from there in terms of
the movies so I'm wondering like for
this specific one are they going to try
to expand upon their universe because
the x-men universe not doing so great
but their solo movies have been awesome
you know Logan was great Deadpool is
great apocalypse not so great x-men
origins great yeah yeah that's as my
curiosity on the subject here because
this guy looks this looks like Roy yeah
Ricky yeah like I don't feel like
Deadpool to when I see this image I've
got a little raw gritty film when I see
that I think of ninja from DeeAnn
towards dad interested I go to community
looked at many especially like seeing
some of the footage both from the the
cartoons and then seeing some of the
images from the comic books and stuff
like it looks like a good I was going to
see the lame team originally but this I
mean he looks like he's in full on cable
mode and I'm excited to see it you know
I'm not even distracted at the moment
that he's also going to be Thanos and
you know he's going to be a villain in
every universe now breakfast I don't
find it distracting all these battles
that was so covered up in makeup I
didn't even know to like five movies in
thy was like Oh Josh Brolin Stannis and
I had no idea that he was bad I was
until I was the first time I saw I was
like this umbrella this really I don't I
could only gonna cook you little I don't
know what they want to do obviously but
it seems like this is a character that
they could kind of put back and forth
between the Deadpool universe and the
yam universe and they wanted to yeah and
you can be like good or evil yeah that
expertise and with the Deadpool no no no
I watch the x-men show and then when I
was watching this video that was
covering some footage from it I was like
oh yeah I remember watching cable on the
show and Josh Brolin is a perfect cassie
choice for it i mean if you look at it
right here that's more accurate than
when you see the x-men characters
dressed Oh
yeah exactly the Deadpool costume is
very accurate and this costume is very
accurate to cable is now go back and
watch x-men United man yeah top-notch
costume and and you know the cable
characters a very serious character and
this is a raw image of cable this is
like a grimy looking cable yeah he looks
like a dude I do I never won them so if
you don't want to talk back to them or
even run across to them and then the
director of this is someone who is one
of the co-directors of job wick so I'm
thinking are they going to make Deadpool
a little more on the serious side this
time around are they going to make it
more of an action heavy seriously
because I hard for me to imagine cable
being a funny character it could be the
serious part of that bulls funny news
yeah they can contrast each other like
that he could be kind of a good foil and
something to kind of you know change the
tone a little bit you know you know add
a bit more of a serious or a gritty
streak good you should always evolve
your tongue a little bit when you're
doing this yeah this is the first one
just to barely had moment I think in the
first half Adele when you're doing like
wave Wilson's origin that's when it
takes time to be a little more serious
but whatever he's Deadpool is just goofy
and we don't have we're passed away
Wilson words in the part now I don't
feel like we would have any serious
Deadpool moments so maybe that would be
a cool balance I have an actual kick-ass
cool menacing villain and then you have
Deadpool is meta humor I'll be like the
kind of realism they're trying to go
with it
well you're not going to overboard with
the cybernetic and stuff so it looks
like a legit person was just like
Trinity yeah this looks like practical
effects yeah it looks like a dude who's
been through a bunch and has been
rebuilt a couple yeah yeah I consider
that he's the son of Scott Summers and
and the clone of Jean Grey yeah because
that's a very specific connection to the
x-men world so now I'm now thinking
maybe they're going to start tying this
in a little more like are they going to
try to rebrand the x-men universe and
have Deadpool's we'll be more inclusive
in it too that was actually concerning
Deadpool is the highest-grossing one and
all the x-men movies Thank You Raven
yeah video the r-rated comedy action oh
yeah I didn't realize it was is it the
highest high
highest-grossing movies I feel like it
at this point the x-men franchise does
kind of need to keep you know evolving
and adding new elements so I wouldn't be
surprised if they're gonna start taking
cues from kids pools I like to me sorry
you guys know I was it to say I mean
they already sort of did with Logan we
had the r-rated Miss already the blood
the Gores when you say Logan I felt like
the excellent franchise was depending on
Logan for so much of it the local
character Hugh Jackman and now that he's
not there I'm wondering whether you
start depending on Deadpool now
especially including especially cuz you
got cable here I don't know man I don't
know if you can end on Deadpool for
x-men overall but you don't know movie
studios I'm gonna do is make decisions
and while the x-men have a decent track
record ya know moving forward especially
with all these changes especially now
with no more Hugh Jackman I am very
curious yeah what will become especially
of the next x-men movie outright yeah
especially with a daughter as well with
an ex on a very thanks rolling it's
right yeah table has included in DX
forces will out he's not part of the
x-force but he is someone who there yeah
he's there alright guys what are your
thoughts I mean what the how K will
looks I think it looks very accurate to
the way the comics looked like maybe not
as bright but that is that's a great
photo right there you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram energy Terpening is at Terp
smith on instagram go Sedaka's photos
he's one sexy mother-effer
and check out our patreon which is a
great website that is it's you know what
I'm trying to say good